it doesn't matter how old you are how
many times you've done it cooking that
holiday meal because there's so much
pressure it can be a little scary
especially if it is your first time yeah
this morning though you're in luck
because we have some tips from the
experts including our very own Candace
Charles who is live at the rizzos in the
southwest Valley with some tasty eats
you can make with the kids Candace good
morning to you
good morning you two good morning folks
Candace Claus is back with a special
treat for you get out your pins get your
PJs on write down these recipes because
I'm going to tell you them really
quickly okay I'm joined by personal
chefs Katie and Nicholas Rizzo thank you
so much for joining us this morning we
got our Junior chefs with us as well
they're part of their this is just what
are we making right now it's
I gotta figure out what exactly this
that's about
Italian yes
it's made with a squidding nice okay
okay now Paxton here is going to show us
how to cut it up I have some interesting
as you guys are oh a new ghost kitchen
tell us a little Bella so we're going
into the new Cloud kitchens rainbow 90.
[Music]
you can
okay oh Candice claws sauces looks like
we're having some issues for me to order
as well so uh it's gonna be something
like you can't find here in the valley
and we're gonna be uh doing all
different types of shapes and flavors so
we're really
awesome fun okay Nicholas you gotta tell
me a little bit about the sauce here
what's on this because it's really easy
so there is a pecorino cheese parmigiano
reggiano and then you just put like a
black pepper olive oil and some pasta
water okay simple enough to make okay
now the cooking classes you guys can
bring your little ones too right super
fun tell me really quickly Paxton what
is your favorite part about cooking guy
cutting stuff
that is awesome you guys okay I got you
covered with all the details about all
of these issues we're making I'm already
made cannoli a little bit earlier on our
website 8newsnow.com of course for about
these two wonderful shelves I'm there as
well as always I'm gonna get back to
cooking you guys I'll see you in a
little bit oh man I wish the Wi-Fi had
not been cutting out a little bit there
but uh cutting stuff